اذا شكرا لاحمد وطبعا هانس فيان معنا يبقى
وهذه الصور الجميله لوصول طبعا واستقبال
طيب بالورد لمئتين 222 شخصا تم اجلائهم من
السودان نحن ننقل هذه الصوره المباشره من
ميناء جده الاسلامي سفينه عسكريه قدرست
هناك قبل ساعه من الان كنا قد شاهدنا وصول
هذه السفينه والان بدات عمليه الاجلاء
ويبدو انها في نهايتها تقريبا هاني صفيان
معنا الان لينقل لنا الصوره من هناك ولكن
قبل ذلك نتحدث عن ان هذه
العمليه طبعا مستمره فيما يتعلق بعمليات
الاجلاء هذه ثاني السفينه حربيه عسكريه
امريكيه تصل الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
لاجلاء رعايه امريكان وايضا من جنسيات
اخرى بحسب ما فهمنا وطبعا نشاهد عدد من
النساء والرجال والاطفال عائلات حقيقه
طبعا تم نقلها من خلال هذه السفينه
الامريكيه لتصل الى السعوديه ومنها طبعا
تتم عمليه النقل الى والعوده الى بلدانهم
اذا عمليه الاستقبال لا زالت مستمره لهذه
العائلات كبار من السن وايضا من الشباب
والصغار نساء ورجالا حضروا ويتم استقبالهم
بالورد وطبعا هدايا ايضا حتى للاطفال
الصغار حملوا معهم ما قله ودل اذا مصحه
تعبير للوصول والخروج من السودان بعد
عشرين يوما من الاقتتال الداخلي هدى مرت
على السودان ولكن الاشتباكات بدل ان تخف
او تتوقف تشتعل اكثر واكثر اليوم تحديدا
في السودان اعتبر الاشتباك فيه الاعنف منذ
بداه الاعلان عن الهدن طبعا عوده وكانها
للنقطه الاولى نشاهد هذا الرجل طبعا
العجوز يتم الاهتمام به لاخراجه من
السفينه بسلامه لم يسجل او لم نعرف حتى
الان اي معلومات ان كان هناك عمليه نقل
واجلاء لمصابين من خلال هذه السفينه ولكن
بحسب ما شاهدنا حتى الان الكل بصحه جيده
رجالا ونساء وايضا اطفال اذا مشاهدينا لا
جديد في السودان سوى ان الصراع العسكري
يدخل يومه العشرين لاشتباكات تجددت وكما
ذكرت هذه المره عنيفه جدا وتشبه الايام
الاولى من الصراع الجيش تمكن من السيطره
على منطقه كوبر وصلاح الاشاره في الخرطوم
بحري كما تقوم قوات الجيش بتمشيط منطقه
كوبر بعد السيطره عليها طبعا وفقا لما
افاد به مراسل العربيه الصور اظهرت
استهداف جوي لتمركزات الدعم السريع في
محيط القصر الجمهوري وايضا القياده العامه
بالخرطوم فيما ردت الاخيره بالمضادات
الارضيه الاوضاع الانسانيه من جهه اخرى
وايضا الطبيه تتفاقم بطريقه مستمره معظم
المرافق الطبيه وعلى راسها المشاف فيه هي
خارج الخدمه خصوصا تلك التي
تتمركز وتتواجد في العاصمه الخرطوم على كل
نعود مشاهدينا لنتحدث عن هذه الصور لا زال
الاستقبال مستمر هدايا للاطفال وورود ايضا
كبارا وصغارا وصلوا نتحدث عن 222 شخصا تم
اجلائهم من السودان عبر السفينه العسكريه
الامريكيه وصلوا الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
هاني صفيان من هناك كان ينقل لنا الصوره
ولا زال حتى الان يبدو هاني ان العمليه
عمليه الاجلاء وصلت الى مرحلتها النهائيه
الان
هاني
نعم ميسون نحن نتحدث عن عشر جنسيات على
متن السفينه العسكريه
الامريكيه والتي تحمل على متنها
222 ولعل ان نصيب الاكبر هم من يحملوننا
الجنسيه السودانيه بعدد
136 شخص وكذلك تليها الجنسيه الامريكيه
بعدد 63 شخصا والباقون متوزعون ما بين
جنسيات من سلوفانيا وعددهم اربعه اشخاص
واربعه اشخاص ايضا من الجنسيه الالمانيه
وجنسيه واحده من المملكه المتحده وهناك
ثلاثه من التريا او اريتريا وايضا ثلاثه
من السويد وواحد من كندا واثنين من
الجنسيه الفرنسيه
وخمسه من الجنسيه السويسريه عموما
اليس كذلك او او اي حالات مرضيه تم نقلها
هذه السفينه مختلفه هذه السفينه مختلفه
كون ان هذه السفينه بخلاف السفينه
الامريكيه التي كانت تحمل ثلاث مصابين
وايضا هي من اصابات التي تعرضوا لها جراء
بعض الشظايا التي كانت بين الطرفي النزاع
ووصلت وطالت هذه الشظايا الى بعض اجسادهم
رغم ان هذه الاصابات لم تكن باصابات خطيره
هذه السفينه تحديدا لا تحمل اي من
المصابين او كذلك من الحالات الطارئه ولكن
ايضا ان هذه السفينه هي ايضا تميزت او
ايضا انها تحمل 63 او 61 طفلا بخلاف ايضا
السفينه الماضيه التي كانت تحمل قرابه
35 طفلا على متنها وما زال اعداد الرعايه
وكما نشاهدهم هنا يقومون من الجسر او من
الرام السفينه الذي يربط ما بين السفينه
وكذلك رصيف ميناء جده الاسلامي الدفعات ما
زالت متواصله ولكن
في بدايه الامر او بدايه النزول كان هناك
الرعايه من السودان او من يحملون الجنسيه
السودانيه هم من قوموا بالنزول اولا وبعد
ذلك قام بالنزول شخص من المملكه المتحده
وايضا هنا نشاهد اعداد الرايه الاخرين حتى
الان لم تقم او لم يقم او لم تقم رعايه
الجنسيه الاخرى بالنزول ولم نشاهدهم ولم
نرصدهم ولكن ما زالوا ما زلنا متاكدين ان
ان هناك عشر جنسيات تحملها هذه السفينه
طبعا السفينه الامريكيه حدث لها الى اين
سيتوجهون
بعد وصولهم وبالمقابل ماذا عن السودانيين
الذين لا يحملون اي جيسيات اخرى
طبعا جميع هؤلاء الرعايه هم اولا سوف
يتوجهون الى الحافلات التي نشاهدها وهذه
اولى الحافلات التي تغادر الان نشاهد
هؤلاء الحافلات تغادر بعد ان اكتمل عدده
لدينا وهذه الحافله الثانيه ايضا تغادر
بعد ان اكتمل عددها طبعا جميع الرعايه
الذين وصلوا على متن هذه السفينه السفينه
لا يحملون سواء التاشيره الطارئه او
تاشيره الدخول الى السعوديه تمكنه تمنح
لهم تاشيره تاشيره طارئه من قبل الجوازات
السعوديه وكذلك المعظم لا يحمل ايضا اي
ثبوتات ويتم اعطاء بعض الاوراق وثبوتات
حتى يتم
او تمكنه من دخول السعوديه بعد ان يتم
التنسيق مع سفرته او قنصليته والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه المعتمده لدى السعوديه فبعد
ذلك يتم منحه هذه الثبوتات وكذلك
التاشيرات الطارئه حتى يتمكن من المغادره
والعوده الى بلاده بعد قدومه من بورسودان
عمليه الاجلاء ستستمر من دول مختلفه لانه
بريطانيا بحسب العواجل التي شاهدناها الان
تقول بان بانها انهت اوسع واطول عمليه
اجلاء لرعايه الدول الغربيه في السودان
في حقيقه الامر تحديدا عن بيان البريطانيا
هناك عمليات اجلال من المفترض ان تنفذها
بريطانيا بين
وايضا اسطول بحري ما بين بورسودان الى
ميناء جده حتى الان لم نرصد هذه السفن
وكذلك من المفترض ان تصل ايضا الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه طائره عسكريه
بريطانيه تحمل عدد من الرعايه وحتى الان
لم تنفذها بحسب المصادر التي حصلت عليها
العربيه
رصد على الارض
سوى فرقاطات او كانت معظم الفرقاطات
العسكريه هي من الهند واتلتها ايضا الصين
وبعد ذلك سفينه واحده فرنسيه الى جانب
ايضا في المرتبه الاولى والتي نفذت اكبر
الاعداد في عمليات الاجراء هي القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه والتي نفذت اكثر
من سته عشره رحله عبر سف جلاله الملك وهي
سفن متعدده سواء لسفن جلاله الملك الرياض
او الجبيل او كذلك مكه او ابهى او الدرعيه
والتي كانت تنفذ بشكل مستمر اما عن
الاسطول او عن الجسر الجوي فقد نفذت ايضا
القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه والتي
تقود هذه المهام الجويه في الجسر الجوي
عمليات اجلاء الى جانب ايضا الطائرات
العسكريه الهنديه
والصينيه وكوريه واضافه الى ايضا
الباكستانيه وهناك ايضا طائره مغربيه من
المفترض ايضا اذا كان هذا البيان او بحسب
البيان الذي اصدرته بريطانيا انه نفذت
اكبر عمليه اجلى فلم نرصد اي من عمليات
الاجلاء التي نفذتها ما بين بورت سودان
وبورتسودان ومن جده اسلامي او كذلك قائده
الملك فيصل البحريه مثلما قامت السفن او
العسكريه الاخرى للدول الاخرى بعيدا عن
بريطانيا بصوره عامه هل هناك من جدول
لرحلات قادمه الان او انه الموضوع
ارتجالي اذا مصحه تعبير بحسب حضور الاشخاص
الى بورد سودان ومن ثم تحميلهم ونقلهم عبر
الامكان الطائرات او عبر السفن
طبعا ما ايضا ما وصلنا
كمصادر خاصه ان عمليات الاجلاء تنفذ بحسب
طلب الدول وايضا بعد وصول رايها الى بورت
سودان والتاكد ايضا من وصولهم لا هناك بعض
الدول لم تستطع تنفيذ عمليات اجلاء
لمواطنيها الذين يقطنون في الخرطوم وكذلك
في المناطق الخطره ما تتم الان من عمليات
اجلاء هم الذين وصلوا بسلام وامان الى
بورت سودان وتم تنسيق مع هذه الدول وايضا
مخاطبه الخارجيه السعوديه التي كانت لها
استجابه سريعه بحسب البيانات التي حصلنا
عليها من عده دول وكذلك التنسيق مع
القنصليه السعوديه هناك في السودان والتي
ايضا اوجدت مقرا في بورسودان وتحديدا في
نادي الموانع يتم فيها اجراء الرعايه
وكذلك تسهيل مهمه بعض الفرقات العسكريه
وتامين المياه الدوليه من قبل القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه عمليه الجلاء هي
مجدوله تحديدا بالنسبه للقوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه التي يتم فيها تنسيق مع
الخارجيه السعوديه وبين القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه والتي هي تعمل باستمرار
في مغادره سفنها من قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه الى العوده بها مؤخرا في ثانيه
نعم تتوقف الان انه في حد زمني او ارقام
محدده ومن ثم سيتم وقف عمليات الاجلاء
لا لا لا هي مستمره ولم تتوقف وايضا سوف
تتم في مسائل هذا اليوم
من عمليات الاجلاء عبر السفن سوف تكون
هناك سفينه امنه وايضا سفينه تابعه للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه سوف تصل في
مسائل هذا اليوم وسوف نرصدها ونواكبها عبر
شاشه العربيه نعم طيب خلينا نتحدث عن
التجهيزات الان طبعا شاهدنا صوره جميله
فيما يتعلق باستقبالهم بالورود وايضا
تقديم بعض الهدايا نعم
قدامك العافيه الحمد لله على سلامتك الله
يسلمك طبعا هذا حديث بين الفريق الطبي هنا
في حرس الحدود والشؤون الطبيه يتم اخذ
اولا للتاكد من السلامه المريض من السكر
من بعض الامراض المعديه وامورها طيبه نحمد
الله طيب كيف حالها طيبه اموره طيبه الحمد
لله دائما الكشف المبدا ياخذ العلامات
الحيويه تاكد من الضغط من السكر فقط لا
غير الامور طيبه الحمد لله رب العالمين
الحمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك ما شاء
الله مهتمين فيك والله انا يعني
مدلعينك انا يا سلام والله
اذا كما تحدث احد الاطباء هنا في الشؤون
الصحيه التابعه التابع لحرس الحدود
السعوديه انهم يقومون باخذ العلامات
الحيويه والتاكد من سلامتها الضغط السكر
ايضا خاصه في مثل هذه الحاله من كبار السن
او من اجره عمليات سابقه وبعد ذلك يتم
اخذهم الى الحافله عبر مقاعد مخصصه لكبار
السن وكذلك هناك مركبات ومتوفره تتواجد
على يمين ويسار هذا الرصيف وايضا هناك
عمليات ايضا موجوده من قبل الكادر الطبي
المنتشر في
اجل اي حاله الابتسامه موجوده على وجوههم
لانه استطاعوا الخروج من السودان والهروب
من الاقتتال الا انه الحاله النفسيه لا شك
بانها متاثره واكيد هناك نوع من الدعم
بهذا الاطار
صحيح صحيح نعم طبعا لا ننسى ان هناك ميسون
خدمات اللوجستيه وحقيقه الامر يعني ما
رصدناه توقعت ان العمليات اللوجستيه هي
امر سهل ليس موضوع مجرد رفع مكالمه هاتف
ويتم التنسيق او اني اتصل بالجهه الفلانيه
رغم ان هناك 30 جهه حكوميه وعسكريه وامنيه
مشتركه وهناك لجان لكن هناك تنسيقات دقيقه
نتحدث عن هذه التنسيقات عند التواصل
تحديدا مع البعثات الدبلوماسيه التي بعضها
لا تعلم بالفعل عن رايها حيث ان بعض
الرايه كما تحدثت انهم لا يحملون بعض
الثبوتات منهم بعض الرعايه التي الذين
فقدوا
ثبوتاتهم اثناء السفر او اثناء انتقالهم
من منطقه الى منطقه في حقيقه الامر ما
رصدناه ان الخارجيه هنا او خارجيه
السعوديه
تعمل بشكل سريع على الدخول او من خلال
التواصل مع البعثات الدبلوماسيه بشكل سريع
حتى يتم تسهيل استخراج هذه الثبوتات حتى
يتم تمكن هؤلاء الركاب هؤلاء الاشخاص الى
الدخول الى السعوديه وبعد ذلك مغادره شكرا
لك على هذه التغطيه كان معنا مراسل
العربيه هاني نصفيان طبعا من ميناء جده
الاسلامي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
على الارض اظهرت مقاطع فيديو تم تداولها
عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي عناصر من
الجيش السوداني في منطقه كوبر والتي تمت
استعاده السيطره عليها بعد معارك عنيفه في
الخرطوم بحري نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا ونشر الجيش السوداني مقطعا مصورا
للمركبات وايضا للاسلحه التابعه للدعم
السريع بعد اشتباكات الاخيره في محيط سلاح
الاشاره بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ايضا
نتابع
[موسيقى]
الله
اكبر
هذا ولم تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخلق
الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في اخرها
اتهم بيان الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن
قصف عشوائي على عدد من مواقع تمركز قواتها
وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه الجديده
التي بدا سريانها اليوم بيان الدعم السريع
اكد ان القصف الذي شنه الجيش بالمدافع
والطائرات يشكل تجاوزا للاعراف والقوانين
الدوليه في المقابل اكد الجيش ان قوات
الدعم السريعه حاولت الهجوم على قياده
منطقه بحر العسكريه الجيش السوداني اضاف
ان قواته دمرت عددا من العربات القتاليه
التابعه للدعم السريع واستلمت خمسه عربات
تم تركها في ميدان المعركه
وقد اظهرت لقطات جويه تصاعد الدخان في
مواقع يعتقد ان قيادات للدعم السريع
تتمركز فيها في الخرطوم بحري مقابل القصر
الجمهوري تحديدا في حي حله حمد والمنطقه
الصناعيه وحي الاملاك
[موسيقى]
ننتقل الى دارفور حيث حذر والي ولايه
الشمال من وقوع كارثه انسانيه بمخيمات
النازحين بعد ان قامت المنظمات الامميه
العامله في المجال الانساني باجلاء موظفها
بسبب تدهور الوضع الامني وقال ان الوضع
الانساني بالولايه ينذر بكرثه حقيقيه قبل
ان يعرب عن قلق حكومته تجاه التطورات
الحاصله هذا ويعيش العاملون في محطات
توليد الكهرباء في جنوب دارفور في مدينه
النيالا او دعم صعبه مع استمرار المواجهات
نتابع
المبادره واخواننا في الكهرباء واخواننا
الاتراك واخواننا السائق اللواري اللي
بيحملوا حقيقه الوقود من بورسودان لميال
يعني هلقيت جينا فقدنا اهوالهم وشفناهم
والان احنا في مسقعه انه كيف يفتح الطريق
عشان كل الناس حاجات يحاول يرجوا ومن خلال
الحاجات السمينه الكميه من الشكاوي يعني
يتعرضوا يمكن
ويتعرض لكثير من الحاجات مثل المشاكل اكيد
يعني كل زول نصيبه من الشيء اللي حصل له
يعني ولذلك يحتسبوا لله لكن خلاص الناس
قادرين انه يقفوا معاهم لحد ما باذن الله
سبحانه وتعالى فاننا امنا في الله كبير
ونعمل السودان كلها يعني باذن الله سبحانه
عليها حتى الناس كلهم توقف صوت الصلاه
وتحتكمل صوت الاكل السودان ومحتاجه الان
للحزب السودان
محتاجنا لحاله والله بتجيد صعبه صعبه بكل
صعوبه يعني ست ايام مرت علينا قبل كذا ما
حصلت علينا سته ايام نهب ودق وسلب وبفضل
الاله وبحمد الله ومن بعده لاخواننا في
الدعم السريع والله هم يعني انقذونا
ادعمونا ماديين ومع نبيا
ويواصل المئات السودانيين نزوحهم نحو مصر
فرينه من المعارك المستمره بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في الايام
الماضيه شهدت المعابر البريه الجنوبيه بين
مصر تزاحما شديدا لعبور عشرات الحافلات
التي تقل السودانيين والاجانب المقيمين
بالبلاد الى مصر
على كل مزيد معنا من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار
ابو شيبه اهلا بك عمار بدايه اخر التطورات
الميدانيه المعلومات المتوفره لديك
اهلا بك ميسون واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
يعني كثير جدا من التطورات الميدانيه التي
كانت في الدقائق
الماضيه وفي هذه اللحظات ايضا ما زال
التحليق الطيران الحربي التابعه للقوات
السودانيه ينتشر فيك سماء منطقه شرق
الخرطوم وهذه المنطقه التي تنتشر فيها
قوات الدعم السريع وتحكم فيها عدد من
الارتكازات وعدد من الطرق الرئيسيه فيها
شاهدنا قبل دقائق من الان طلعات جويه كانت
باتجاه هذه المنطقه منطقه شرق الخرطوم
والتي تحاذي منطقه المطار ومحيط المطار
وفي هذه المنطقه ايضا كذلك من تحصينات
ودفاعات او دفاعات او انتشار كثيف لقوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه هذه الطلعات
الجويه للطيران الحربي ترى مركزت على هذه
النقاط وردت عليها المضادات الارضيه التي
تتواجد الارض لقوات الدعم السريعه لكنها
لم تصب تلك الطائرات على الميدان ايضا
هنالك تطورات
على مستوى ولايه الخرطوم من الحظ ذلك من
خلال ربما تصاعد ليعمل الدخان الكثيف من
عدد من المناطق المجاوره لقياده الجيش في
منطقه وسط الخرطوم وايضا بحسب مصادر
ميدانيه تحدثنا اليها اشارت الى اشتباكات
تدور في هذه اللحظات في المناطق المحيطه
بالقصر الرئاسي ومعروف ان هذه المناطق منذ
نهار الامس وحتى الصبح اليوم وحتى نهار
اليوم كانت تشهد اشتباكات تجددت هذه
الاشتباكات قبل لحظات من جديد في محاوله
جديده من الجيش للتوغل في هذه المنطقه
التي تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم السريع منطقه
القصر الرئاسي وما فيها من شوارع فرعيه
وشوارع الرئيسيه مهمه جدا خاصه وان الجيش
كان قد انفتح وانتشر واستطاع من خلال هذا
الصباح الدخول الى منطقه سلاح الاشاره
بمدينه بحري حيث كانت تتواجد قوات الدعم
السريع وحتى يتم تضييق الخناق في تلك
المنطقه كان لابد من السيطره على منطقه
سلاح الاشاره وهي منطق استراتيجيه جدا في
مدينه بحري حيث تنتشر وتسيطر قوات الدعم
السريع على مناطق كثيره جدا خاصه في
البلده القديمه
معنا من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه كشف المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه الدكتور محمد
ابراهيم للعربيه كشف عن توقفي 93 مستشفى
عن الخدمه من اصل 143 طبعا في مناطق
النزاع مؤكدا ان هناك اكثر من 200 حاله
وفاه جراء الاشتباكات تم توثيقها حتى الان
عدد الاصابات 342 اصابه في الغطائين العام
الخاص الوفيات 2007 حاله وفاه في القطاعين
العام والخاص وهذه الموثقه اما بتحويل الى
المشرحه او شهادات الوفاه هذه من واقع
السجلات الطبيه
والارغام الاحصائيه الصحيه بالنسبه لعدد
المستشفيات في ولايه الخرطوم يوجد 134
مستشفى عام يتبع للغطاء العام والقطاع
الخاص هذه المستشفيات موزعه على السبع
محليات التي تشكل ولا تخلطون
الذي يعمل فيها منها
ثلاثه تدعيم مستشفى بخروج عدد اثنين
مستشفى اليوم
الامم المتحده من جانبها قالت انها تحتاج
الى 445 مليون دولار لمساعده 860 الف شخص
قد يفرون بحلول اكتوبر القادم من القتال
الدامي في السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع مفوضيه الامم المتحده الساميه
لشؤون اللاجئين
اخرجت النداء لجمع الاموال من الدول
المانحه كما قالت الامم المتحده في بيان
مضيفه ان مصر وجنوب السودان
اكبر عدد من الوافدين
وفي تصريحات للعربيه اعرب سفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي في القاهره عن قلقه من الحرب في
السودان اضاف ان تعامل مصر بحرص على
حدودها مبرر حتى لا يتسلل الارهابيون
اليها
نحن قلقون عندما تدور اشتباكات مثل هذه
وتتحول لحرب لان هذا يعطي المساحه دائما
لذوي الافكار المتطرفه والارهابيه اننا
نرى ما تفعله مصر الان وهي تتعامل بحرص
على الحدود لتتاكد من عدم تسرب ارهابيين
من خلال حدودها مع السودان واعتقد اننا
سنناقش هذا على المستوى الثنائي مع
نظرائنا المصريين لنرى امكانيه التعاون في
هذا الموضوع
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم دكتوره هويدا محمد
الحسن عضو منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل
حقوق الانسان اهلا بك دكتوره اسمحي لي انا
ابدا بصوره الوضع على الصعيد الطبي
والانساني وهل هي بالفعل قاتمه كما نستمع
من هنا وهناك من تقارير مختلفه
السلام
والمجد والخلود لشهداء
لشهدائنا وعاجل الشفاء لجرحانه وشكرا
لقناتكم
وتخطيطها المستمره للاحداث لسودان
وكل يوم يمر علينا بزداد الامر سوء
ورقه من مصابي الحرب فقط ولكن ظهرت
الامراض الاخرى وامراض الاطفال ومرضى غسيل
الكلى اتحدث من منطقه شرق النيل يعني
اليوم فقط حسب وصلت الينا حوالي 19 اصابه
وحصلت اربعه وفيات هذه الوفيات هي اثنين
مرضى كلى وفيهم طفل صغير برضو ايضا لانه
هو كان عنده
جوني عارفه كيف بالعربيه راغان او جون ديس
وما لذا العنايه يعني كانت كل هذه الاصابه
بماذا دكتوره هويدا اسمحيلي
19 اصابه كانت اصابات رصاص
ولكن يقابلها ايضا امراض تحتاج للعلاج
وكان هناك اربع وفيات بسبب امراض لم يستطع
احد تقديم العلاج لها
الوصول الى اماكن تلقيهم العلاج فيهم
اثنين حالات مرضى كلى وطفل فقير وفي اثنين
حالات وفاه نتيجه وقوع دانا بمنطقه بريه
يعني في اثنين حالات وفاء وقعت دانه في
منطقه بري وصل الينا مصابين من منطقه بوري
والمشكله الاساسيه هي عدم توفر الادويه
والعلاجات ام ان المشكله هي صعوبه الوصول
الى المكان الصحيح يعني هؤلاء وصولهم الى
مراكزهم حيث يتلقون العلاج
فتتوقف مناطق اما مستشفيات غسيل الكلى
لعدم تمكن المرضى من الوصول اليها او
تتوقف
بسبب قطع التيار الكهربائي يعني المستشفى
اللي انا موجوده فيه يوجد فيه منطقه غسيل
كلى لكن بالامس لم يعمل هذا المركز نسبه
لانقطاع التيار الكهربائي وانقطاع الماء
منه وعدم وجود وقود كافي لتشغيل المولد
نعم هذه المشكله من المشاكل وايضا فيما
يتعلق بالكلى نحن نتحدث عن امراض اخرى
امراض السرطان وغيرها من الامراض المزمنه
التي تحتاج الى مراعاه
نعم لضياء الان مستشفى البان جديد هو يعني
يستقبل مصابين الجرحى والنساء والتوليد
فقط
ولذلك ياتون بالرغم هذا المشفى كان يعمل
بجميع التخصصات قبل الحرب يعني كان به
جميع التخصصات الاطفال الباطنيه الانف
والاذن والحنجره الاسنان الان هذا
المستشفى مغلق تمام
ا
جرب وقسمه النساء والتوليد ياتوا الينا
كميه من المرضى ولا ندري كيف نؤديهم
وتوجيههم ونقدم لهم فقط المساعدات والاز
عافات لكنهم يحتاجون لعلاجات مستمره بعض
منهم لا يمكن توقف العلاج منهم عنهم
فهؤلاء هم الكارثه الكبرى
بالاضافه الى العلاج يقدم يقوم بعمليات
جراحيه او لا غير قادر المستشفى نعم هذا
المستشفى يقوم بعمليه جراحيه
والحكايه
يعني نحن يعني في يوم من الايام هذا غرفه
العمليه لا تتوقف غرفه العمليه لا تتوقف
تماما ونحن الان يعني حتى احنا يعني اخذنا
على روحنا رزق كبير مخاطر الكبرى لانه حتى
التعقيم لا يتم الصوره الصحيحه ولا
الجرعات الدوائيه تتم كما يجب يعني لكننا
مستمره كافيه دكتوره
والله العظيم ليس هناك كافيه ولذلك نحن
نخرج المرضى بعد عشر ساعات او 12 ساعه من
اجراء عمليات كبيره الا الانسان لنرى انه
هو
لمراقبه ده بنتركه بالمشفى لكن الذين يعني
تتم عملياتهم بصوره ثالثه ولا توجد اليهم
مضاعفات يتم اخراجهم في اقل من المده
الممكنه يعني انا مثلا انا استشاري نساء
وتوليد اما القيصريات انا اخرج النساء بعد
عشره ساعات من اجراء العمليه بعد وجود عن
الطاقه وماذا عن الطاقم الطبي
قليل جدا لذلك لا استطيع
متابعته ومتابعه دقيقه نعم
بسيط جدا
ارهق تماما يعني
نعاني من مشكله غضع الكهرباء يعني
بالامثله اجريت عمليه
بنور التلفون يعني بنور الموبايل يعني
ثلاث مرات اعمل قيصريات من غير كهرباء
يعني
الله يقويكم شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم
دكتوره هويدا محمد الحسن عضو منظمه اطباء
السودان من اجل حقوق الانسان على هذه
المداخله وكل التوفيق لكم
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء واصلت
نيجيريا اجلاء المئات من رعاياها الفرينه
من القتال في السودان واعادتهم الى بلادهم
بعد ايام من التاخير الذي ترك العديد منهم
عالقين كانت مفوضيه نيجيريين في الشتات قد
اوضحت في وقت سابق ان حوالي الفين جيري
تقطعت بهم السبل منذ بدء الاشتباكات في
السودان
وبهذا الاطار قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه انه تم تسهيل عبور ما لا يقل عن
4000 شخص من جنسيات مختلفه عبر المنافذ
الحدوديه مع السودان بالاضافه الاستقبال
اكثر من الف لاجئ سوداني
حتى الان تم تسهيل عبور اكثر من 4000 شخص
من 61 دوله عبر المنافذ الحدوديه مع
السودان وتم السماح ل 75 رحله جويه لعبور
الاجواء الاثيوبيه لاجلاء رعاياها من
السودان انطلاقا من مسؤوليتنا ما يحدث في
السودان سيكون له تاثير سلبي على اثيوبيا
مزيد معنا من الخرطوم المحلل العسكري
الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين اهلا بك سيدي
اسمح لي ان ابدا بقراءه بالمشهد الان
الاشتباكات هي الاعنف منذ فتره طويله
لماذا برايك هي مرتبطه بماذا شو المعطيات
التي ادت للتصعيد هذا بهذا الشكل مع هدنه
جديده
غالبا ما يكون هذا التصعيد بسبب
استجماع
التمرد قواه بشكل كبير لكي يحدث قدرا من
المكاسب على الارض خاصه بعد ان يعني نجحت
الجهود في ان يكون هنالك اللقاء ما بين
ممثل من الدعم السريع وممثل من القوات
المسلحه انا اعتقد انه يريد ان يكسب يعني
موته قدم يمكنه او يحقق له يعني موقف
تفاوضي يستطيع من خلاله ان يناور بخلاف ما
تسعى اليه القوات المسلحه القوات المسلحه
النصر عسكري مرتقب من خلال هذه المناوشات
بقدر ما هي ورقه تستخدم خلال التفاوض هذا
ما تقوله
لا يمكن ان يكون التمرد نصرا العسكريه
عزيزتي ميسون
فريق فتح الرحمن لاي من الطرفين لانه لانه
كما تقول يعني انت تصف الدعم السريع
بالمتمردين ولكن ايضا الدعم السريع ونشاهد
بالصور انه ايضا طيران الجيش مستمر
بعمليات القذف
عزيزتي التمرد هذا يقاتل الشعب السوداني
وليس قوات المسلحه تمر هذا ضد الشعب
السوداني الان الشعب السوداني بكلياته
يلتفت حول
يمكن ان نتحدث عن النص لهذا التمرد ايا
كان حجمه وايا كان شكله ايا كان الدعم
الاقليمي الذي ياتي اليه هذا يعني اتحدث
على فهمت عليك استاذ فتح الرحمن ولكن
النقطه الرئيسيه عندما اقول نصر على
المستوى عسكري بمعنى اخر اي استفاده
عسكريه من هذا التحرك لن تكون الا لكي
يستخدمها كورقه بمعنى اخر انه لن تتغير
المعادله العسكريه على الارض من خلال هذه
التحركات احنا عم نقرا قراءه عسكريه مش عم
ناخذ مواقف
زراعه عسكريه انا اقول لك هذه كلها جهود
لن تغير من المشهد العسكري اي شيء على ارض
الواقع وقت المسلحه طفر السيطره كامله
ويزعم لكي يعزز موقفه في المنطقه المحيطه
بالقصر الجمهوري يزعق لكي يحتل منطقه يعني
واليوم سنه هجوم على مدينه
قوات كانت تاتي مفترض تعزيز قواته في
الخرطوم يسال انه وجهها بان تهاجم مدينه
على امل ان يحتل هذه المدينه ويكون لهم
الان التمرد ليست لديه مت واحد يتفاوض
حوله ليست لديه موطيه قدم اصلا كلما
معسكراته تحت سيطره القوات المسلحه كل
المراكز التي كان يتجمع فيها تحصيت
الاطرابات المسلحه
يدفعنا للتساؤل هل يمكن لذلك الوضع اذا
كان صحيحا على الارض ليس لديه اي موقع قدم
او موقع قدم بالاحرى ان تستمر العمليات
للانتهاء من العمليه العسكريه بصوره كامله
دون اللجوء الى التفاوض
العمليه العسكريه ان كانوا يريدون ان
يحلونها دون اللجوء للتفاوض لحلت ولكن
ستكون هنالك تكلفه يعني البشريه كبيره من
الضحايا التكلفه في البنيه التحتيه الغرض
من التفاوض عزيزتي هو اخراج هذا التمرد من
وسط الاحياء السكنيه ومن المرافق الخدميه
حتى لا تتضرر البنيه التحتيه وحتى لا تكون
هنالك خسائر كبيره في المدنيين هذا هو
الغرض من التفاوض اذا الغرض من التفاوض
الغرض منه تحسين تحسين الظروف المعيشيه
للمواطن تحسين الاوضاع الانسانيه للمواطن
الاحاديث الدكتور هويدا وهي تتحدث بمستشفى
البنج لكن يعني عيب عليها انها كانت تجي
من تحدثك عن ان التمرد يحتل عشر مستشفيات
في الخرطوم وحولها الى عسكريه بالامس
بالامس من حيث تتواجد وتنقل لنا الصوره
بحسب المعلومات المتوفره لديها
يعني في مراقب دوله مش مراقب دوله وكانت
تجيب على الاسئله التي سالتها على كل من
الخرطوم المحلل العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن
محي الدين شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات
[موسيقى]
على كل المشاهدينا منذ اولى ساعات
المواجهه بين الجنرلين تحول القصر
الجمهوري الجديد بالسودان الى بؤره رئيسيه
للصراع طبعا هذا القصر هذا القصر الذي كان
حتى الامس القريب مقر للرئيس ولنوابه باتا
اكثر النقاط اشتعالا انتقلت منه
الاشتباكات بسرعه لمواقع وايضا لمناطق
اخرى من بينها محيط القياده العامه للجيش
وايضا مطار الخرطوم هذا القصر ما قر
العاصمه الخرطوم ويتكون من ثلاثه طوابق
كما نشاهد ولكن من يسيطر فعليا عليه واين
تدور هذه الاشتباكات طبعا هناك يتجاذب
طرفاء الصراع السيطره على الاقل اعلاميا
قوات الدعم السريع اعلنت سيطرتها على
القصر وذلك قبل اسبوعين ولكن الجيش خرج
مرارا ليمفي ما وصفه بالمعلومات المضلله
وايضا التي قال بانها كاذبه غير ان قوات
الدعم السريع نشرت بدورها فيديو نشرت
فيديو لعناصرها تقول بانهم من داخل القصر
مؤكده بسط سيطرته عليه واحتفاظها بمواقع
استراتيجيه اخرى من بينها ايضا مطار
الخرطوم حاليا الاشتباكات لا تزال مندلعه
بين الطرفين في محيط القصر لكنها تخطت
المواجهات بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني الاخير استخدم قوات الشرطه ايضا
الاحتياطيه وذلك من كافه الولايات وهي ما
وصفتها قوات الدعم السريع بالقوه المقاتله
وايضا القوه المعاديه وفي وقت يحاول الجيش
وقوات الاحتياط التقدم نحو القصر تحت غطاء
جوي تتصدى قوات الدعم باسلحه رشاشه وايضا
بمضادات للطائرات
ومن التطورات السودانيه الى التصعيد بين
روسيا واوكرانيا في الحرب الدائره هناك
حيث اعلنت موسكو انها قررت تجديد
الاجراءات الامنيه بعد الهجوم الذي استهدف
الكرملين بطائرتين مسيرتين ووصفته موسكو
بمحاوله ارهابيه لاغتيال بوتين وبينما نفت
اوكرانيا علاقتها بالهجوم موجهه الكريم
اصابع الاتهام الى واشنطن التي نفت هي
الاخرى ضلوعها فيه مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا في التفاصيل شدد المتحدث
باسم الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض جون
كيربي شدد على ان بلاده لا تشجع او تمكن
اوكرانيا من ضرب اهداف خارجه حدودها وفق
وسائل اعلام محليه قربي اكد ان مزاعم
روسيا بان الولايات المتحده تقف وراء
الهجوم على كاذبه على حد قوله
هذا الرد الامريكي جاء بعد ان اتهمت موسكو
الولايات المتحده وبشكل مباشر بالضلوع في
الهجوم على الكرملين حيث قالت ان القرار
قرار الهجوم اتخذ في واشنطن وليس pdf قال
الناطق الرسمي باسم
ان موسكو على درايه ان شنكييف لهذه
النوعيه من الضربات يكونوا باملاء من
واشنطن اضاف ان بلاده تعتقد ان كيد متورطه
في الهجوم بناء على بيانات من الاستخبارات
الروسيه الكرملين قال ايضا انه يدرس
مجموعه متنوعه من الخيارات للرد على
الهجوم الاخير
ردا على سؤال حول انكار اوكرانيا
والولايات المتحده تورط في هجمات الطائرات
بدون طيار
محاولتكيف وواشنطن مثيره للضحك تماما ندرك
ان القرار بشان مثل هذه الاعمال والهجمات
لم يتم اتخاذه في كييف بل في واشنطن وبعد
ذلك تفعل اوكرانيا ما يطلب منها ليست كيف
من تقوم بتحديد الاهداف واختيار الوسائل
بلواشنطن كيف تقوم بتنفيذها فقط ونحن ندرك
ذلك
[موسيقى]
وفي ردود الافعال الدوليه المستمره اعتبرت
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
على الكرملين باستخدام المسيرات حادث غريب
وغامض ولا يزال بحاجه الى تفسير حيث قالت
بانه ليس لديها اي معلومات محدده حول هذا
الموضوع ولا يمكنها مناقشه الروايات
المتعلقه به
وبدورها اعتبرت الخارجيه الايطاليه ان اي
عمل عسكري بما فيه محاولات استهداف مبنى
الكرملين في روسيا اعتبرته امرا لا يخدم
التسويه السياسيه السلميه في اوكرانيا
وقالت الخارجيه الايطاليه ان جميع الهجمات
التي تسببت بالضرر على مبنى الكرملين لا
يعرف تفاصيلها لحد اللحظه وانها لا تخدم
السلام الذي يجب ان يكون في مصلحه
اوكرانيا والذي سينتج عنه استقلال
اوكرانيا على حد قوله
للمزيد معنا من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا تعمي اهلا بك كاتيا كل الدول تريد
تفسيرات حول ما حدث اي جديد
مرحبا ميسون حقيقه اليوم كانت اصابع
الاتهام فعلا توجهت الى واشنطن بانها هي
التي تقف وراء هذا الحادث كما تتحدث طبعا
كان قد قال ان واشنطن هي التي تقوم بتدبير
كل شيء وان كيف هي التي تقوم بالتنفيذ
وهذا ما اعاد واكد عليه نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي الذي قال ان واشنطن هي التي
قامت
بتلقين اوكرانيا لتنفيذ هذه هذا الحادث
وبالتالي هي خطوه تصعيديه اخرى كبيره كما
اعتبرها مدريديف طبعا الخارجيه الروسيه
ادانت هذا العمل ودعت المجتمع الدولي ايضا
لادانه الحادث حادث استهداف الكرملين
واستهداف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اعتبرت ان لا يوجد لدى كيف اي نوايا لتقوم
بعمليات محادثه سلميه
هذا هذا الحادث وهذا الحدث يؤكد على ذلك
طبعا كان هناك ميسون منذ الصباح استهداف
مكثف للاراضي الروسيه
باستخدام المسيرات كان هناك استهداف لاكثر
من منطقه في روسيا في منطقه فارونج وفي
منطقه ايضا كروس كان هناك استهداف باربع
سيارات مصفاه نفط انضلع نتيجتها الحريق
كبير لذلك هذه الحمله هي نشهدها خلال
الاسبوع الاخير
وبالاخص الاستهداف الاخير الذي هو يتزامن
مع الاستعدادات لاحتفالات عيد النصر التي
ستشهدها العاصمه الروسيه موسكو والتي لا
تزال قائمه كما اكد الكريندن اليوم بان
هذه الاحتفالات ستكون قائمه وان الرئيس
الروسي
وعلى الرغم من الحادث سيكون سيقوم بالقاء
خطاب خلال هذا الاحتفال في عيد النصر الذي
سيكون في التاسع من الشهر الجاري ميسون
وبالمقابل هل اتضحت الصوره عن طبيعه الرد
الروسي ام ما حدث اليوم كافن ربما
حقيقه كما قال الكرملين الرد سيكون مناسبا
يعني موسكو تدرس كما قال ايضا
خيارات متعدده للرد على هذا الاستهداف كما
قال بانه سيكون او يصب بالمصالح الروسيه
لذلك حتى الان من الصعب التخمين ما هو
الرد الروسي سيكون على هذا الحادث لن يكون
فقط لن يقتصر على التصريحات ولكن من حسب
ردود فعل كثيرا لروسيا على حوادث مشابهه
كانت قد قامت بتكثيف الضربات العسكريه
للاراضي الاوكرانيه ردود فعل الشارع
وطبيعه تعاطي الاعلام مع ما حدث بالامس من
استهداف
يعني هو كانت بمثابه تحليلات لكيفيه وصول
هذا الجسم او هذه المسيره الى الكرملين
كان هناك عده تحليلات منها ما نتطرق الى
ان هذه المسيره اطلقت من خارج او من ضواحي
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو ومنها تحدثت عن
انها اطقت في مناطق مجاوره الى الكرملين
ولكن جميعها طبعا حتى الان هي تصبي بمثابه
التحليلات ولكن حتى الان لم يكن هناك اي
توضيح رسمي عن كيفيه وصول هذه المسيره الى
الكرملين وعن ايضا نوعيه هذه المسيرات
التي استخدمت لاستهداف الكرملين كلها
بعدما تم فتح تحقيق جنائي من قبل الكرملين
يوم امس ستكون واضحه بعد الانتهاء طبعا من
عمليات التحقيق ميسون مراسله العربيه
كاتيا طعمي شكرا جزيلا لك
طبعا نشير الى العواجل كونه الجزء الاول
من النشره كان يتركز على السودان وهناك
تطورات جديده تتعلق
بامر تنفيذي من بايدن الرئيس الامريكي
بمعاقبه كل من يزعزع استقرار السودان
نوافقكم بالمزيد حول طبيعه هذا الامر وعلى
من يمكن له ان يطبق في سياق هذه النشره او
نشرات لاحقه على كل ادعى الرئيس الاوكراني
الى انشاء محكمه خاصه لمحاكمه روسيا على
غزوها بلاده مطالبا بتحقيق عداله واسعه
واسعه النطاق عبر القانون رافضا فكره
الافلات الهجين من العقاب زيلينسكي اكد
ايضا ان روسيا يجب ان تتحمل المسؤوليه
كامله في حربها في اوكرانيا
قالت الصين ان هناك حاجه الى اليقظه شديده
لمواجهه توسع الناتو شرقا في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ وجاء هذا بعد ورود تقارير
تفيد بان حلف شمال الاطلسي يخطط لانشاء
مكتب في اليابان لتسهيل المشاورات مع
الحلفاء والشركاء الامنيين في المنطقه
المتابعه
هي مقر السلام والاستقرار وارض واعده
للتعاون والتنميه ولا ينبغي ان تصبح ساحه
معركه للمنافسه الجيوسياسيه توسع الناتو
المستمر شرقا في منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ وتدخله في الشؤون الاقليميه
سيقضيان حتما على السلام الاقليمي
وسيشجعان الكتلى على مواجهه بعضها البعض
ما يعني ان على دول المنطقه ان تكون في
حاله تاهب قصوى
الى تداعيات التصعيد بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين كشف تحقيق اول لسلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي بان منظومه القبه الحديديه
اصابها خلل فني في جوله التصعيد الاخيره
على قطاع غزه التحقيق اشار الى ان الخلل
الفني حاله دون اعتراض صواريخ اطلقت من
غزه وسقطت في سدرويد
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت وزاره الصحه عن مقتل
سيده وثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين برصاص القوات
الاسرائيليه في كل من بلده حواره والبلده
القديمه بنابلس بالضفه الغربيه جاء هذا
بعد ان قامت قواته اسرائيليه خاصه معززه
بقوات كبيره من الجيش بمحاصره الشبان
الثلاثه ومداهمتهم في احد المنازل الواقعه
في حي الياسمينه شمال الاراضي الفلسطينيه
هذا وقالت مصادر للعربيه ان الهجوم الذي
جنته اسرائيل على مطار النيرب السوري في
حلب مطلع الشهر الجاري استهدف لاول مره
مركبات دفاع جوي ايرانيه ذكرت المصادر ان
الغارات الاسرائيليه على المطار استمرت 50
دقيقه وشاركت فيها ست مقاتلات المصادر
افادت ان طائرات شركه كاشم فارس للطيران
وسلاح الجو الايراني هبطت في الفتره
الاخيره في مطار النيرب في اطار مسار نقل
معدات عسكريه وايضا معدات حساسه اخرى لحزب
الله
بينما اعلنت السلطات البريطانيه استعدادها
لحفل تتويج الملك تشارز ستصبح قرينته
كامله ملكه خلال الحفل حيث تنتظرها تحديات
كبيره لتكسب ثقه الناس متابعه
[موسيقى]
هي حب حياتي تشارلز منذ شبابه وزوجته خلال
العقدين الماضيين بعد اعتلاء تشارلز العرش
اصبحت الملكه القرينه لكنها بعيون الناس
كانت دائما المراه الاخرى كما ظلت دائما
محل مقارنه بالاميره ديانا زواجها من ولي
العهد لم يكن ضمن خططها المستقبليه ولا
ضمن توقعاتها حتى
فاجات تشارلز العالم بزواجه من كاميلا عام
2005 وكان ثاني زواج لكليهما لم تحضر
الملكه اليزابيث حينها الزواج المدني
ولكنها باركت هذا الزواج لاحقا كما علمنا
في وقت لاحق من خلال تصريحات هاري اللاذعه
ضد العائله بانه وشقيقه ويليام توسل
تشارلز الا يتزوج كملا لكن ذلك لم يردعه
حينها
كما ولدت عام
1947 لعائله غنيه ووالدها ضابط متقاعد من
الجيش ارتبطت بضاب في سلاح الفرسان يدعى
اند في منتصف الستينات لكنها تعرفت الى
تشارلز مطلع السبعينات ووقع في حبها منذ
اللحظه الاولى بحسب احد كتاب السيره
الذاتيه
ظل قريبا من كاميلا وزوجها السابق وكان
عرابا لطفلهما الاول تزوج تشارلز ديانا
عام
1981 ولكن ظلت كاملا جزءا من حياته
وكلفتها علاقته السريه به صورتها امام
البريطانيين الذين لطالما نظروا اليها
كمخربه لزواج تشارلز بديانا
ورغم تاكيدات تشارلز ان علاقته بكامله لم
تستانف الا بعد انهيار زواجه من ديانا الا
ان ديانا كانت تعتبر خلاف ذلك
ففي مقابلتها الشهيره عام
1995 افصحت كنا ثلاثه في هذا الزواج
تلاقوا كاملا كان عام
1995 في حين انتهى زواج تشيلسي وديانا
رسميا عام
1996 بعد وفاه ديانا عام
1997 انسحبت كاملا من المشهد
لكندا في حياته ليتزوجا بعدها في احتفاليه
مدنيه صغيره في ظل الجدل حول لقبها كملكه
محتدما خلال حكم الملكه اليزابيث التي
منحت كاملا لقب الملكه القرينه قبل وفاتها
بعده اشهر خلال الاحتفال بيوبيلها
البلاتيني
صوره كامل قرينه للملك لا زالت مهتزه
وشخصيتها مثاره جدلا وانقسامات في الشارع
البريطاني قصر باكينز حاول تحسين صوره
كاميرا امام عامه الناس وكمل بذل جهودا
حديثا للاعتراف بها في العائله لكن
بالنسبه للبريطانيين الزجاج المكسور لا
يعود كما كان ووفاه الاميره ديانا كسرت
قلوب البريطانيين الذي ينظر الكثير منهم
لكاميرا على انها الملام في ماساه ديانا
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا هذه الساعه الاخباريه قد انتهت
ولكن التغطيه مستمره حول التطورات في
السودان على راس الساعه مع المشاهدين
ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات